thank
[Music]
you
hello everyone and welcome to another
edition of humor talks where I talk with
different thought leaders on humor in
the workplace and extensions from that
today we're going to be talking to Paul
Smith he is the director of consumer
research at PNG but also the author of
lead with the story which has been
featured in Forbes time CIO and other
places as well how are you doing today
Paul very good good to talk to you
excellent uh so Paul you and I shared a
training stage a couple of years ago at
uh Procter and Gamble and I was there
talking about leadership and uh humor
and you were there talking about
leadership kind of through storytelling
so you've also written a book called
lead with a story which I've started to
read and I think it's fantastic but tell
us a little bit what's the idea behind
um lead with the story yeah well and and
I was glad to meet you there the
unfortunate thing is I didn't get to
stay and uh and hear your stuff so uh so
I think you owe me one actually
something yes okay yeah I think I catch
up with you um you know the idea behind
the book is uh I mean the title is lead
with a story and we're here talking
about storytelling but but first and
foremost it's a book on leadership and
storytelling is just the vehicle and
it's an admittedly unlikely vehicle but
uh but the book is about how to make you
a better leader and all of and all of
that entails
um you know and I could probably help
you understand it better by telling you
what it's not because it's been confused
by some folks just based on the title
they'll they'll think oh so so this is a
book that's basically trying to tell me
if I've got a big sales presentation or
some big meeting and I've got to give a
speech or something that I need to lead
off with a story or a joke or something
like to break the ice and that's not at
all what I'm talking about I'm talking
about using storytelling to actually
deliver your leadership message and
to affect the change that you want not
as some kind of a A lead-in or a Cheesy
Icebreaker or some afterthought later
I'm actually talking about using
storytelling to replace the normal
management speak that we would engage in
in the office to be more effective
element of sometimes with humor in the
workplace or doing things a little bit a
little bit differently people are like
oh well yeah I'll just tell a random
joke that has no relevance to what it is
I'm talking about breaking the ice which
there's a little bit of value to I think
but you're talking about that next level
of using storytelling as yeah again
really telling your message that it's
directly tied in and doesn't seem kind
of just out of uh left field in terms of
the audience of like why would they say
that about this whole thing it's like no
it's a story that actually gives
credibility and so what was kind of the
how did you come to find this idea of
um the power of story what got you into
you know getting to the point that
you're like you know what I need to
write a book about this
yeah so I I guess maybe I'm a slow
learner I've been working at PNG for 20
years now and it probably took me 15 to
realize that storytelling was an
important
uh skill that I needed to have and I
guess I just finally realized after
identifying the leaders at at that
company and others that I admired that I
wanted to be like
um you know when I grew up in the
company or the ones that I wanted to
work for if I if I looked at those
people and I tried to decide what they
had in common their their ability to
tell a compelling story was one of those
things and it dawned on me that they
didn't teach me that in business school
you know so I wasn't really prepared for
that skill set and so I set about you
know learning everything I could about
it and I I bought and read all the books
I could find on the subject and
and I left even with an even stronger
conviction that I needed to know how to
do this well but still didn't know how
to do it and and that's when I realized
well if I if I want to know this
probably some other people do as well so
that's I said I can't find the book that
I'm looking for I'm just gonna have to
write it because somebody needs to and
and so what what I ended up putting in
it were the two things that I couldn't
find in any of the other books and the
first one is really how do you tell a
good business story because it's that's
very different than you know the way you
would write a screenplay for a Hollywood
movie or write a romance novel I mean
those are stories too but they're a
they're much longer but they're just
different and so I tried to to write a
book that would actually teach people
how to do it and that's one thing that
was missing from all the others but the
other thing was I just I needed a bunch
of stories and as I as I interviewed
people
um senior leaders at a bunch of
companies and I I tried to find out why
are people not using storytelling more
often the the thing I found out was
first of all most of them don't realize
they should be telling stories but even
the ones that do the main reason they
don't tell more stories is they just
don't have any to tell and so that's the
other thing I wanted my book to do would
be to give you a hundred stories that
you can actually use so not not just as
an example of hey here's an example of
how you can use a story in a business
setting you know if that's all I wanted
to do the book would have been very very
short I actually wanted to give people
and here are these 20 or 21 leadership
challenges here five or six stories that
you could use in each of these
leadership challenges and you could
actually use the same story yourself to
successfully navigate that situation so
it was a way to jump start people's
personal collection of stories that they
need to add upon but I wanted to give
them a place to start
yeah and I think that's what I really
appreciate about the book as someone
that is like yeah I want to get in and
do this as I'm going through it I love
you know multiple elements of it at
first that you know you tell the power
of story and talk about its benefits but
you go beyond that and you help those
people that are like yeah if I wanted to
start to do this they have direct
examples that they can use in terms of
here's a perfect story on leadership in
this uh kind of this situation but then
you also help through the process help
to train people how to create their own
stories or the elements of a good story
so that if they have their own kind of
personal thing that they think they can
relate to it they start to have these
new kind of guidelines to do it so I
think it's really helpful in terms of
actually getting people to do the
storytelling and to your point you know
people are why don't people use
storytelling well they don't have
examples or they don't know how and so I
think this covers uh the mold for that
that's the idea
very cool so
um what are some of the ways we talked
about it as a leadership uh um kind of
as helping to provide leadership but
what are some of the the direct benefits
that you notice you know you do it and
use it at Procter and Gamble what are
the the reasons that people are like you
know what yeah we want to use story uh
what are the things that it helps with
yeah well it it helps because you can't
just order somebody to be more creative
or start loving your job or get more
inspired right or right work more
smarter or collaboratively or be a
better Problem Solver or you know you
know Drew what you really need to do you
need to think outside the box more you
know if you just start doing that you
great employee
you just can't tell people
to do those things because the human
brain doesn't work that way you have to
show them and a story is the best way to
show them you show them how somebody
else was creative or tell them a story
that'll help them appreciate and love
their job more or tell them an inspiring
story that will inspire them or tell
them a story about how somebody else was
thinking outside of the box and it can
show them how to you just can't order
people to do stuff that involves the
creative part of their brain because
humans don't respond to that the stories
stories can do that
yeah yeah that element of inspiration I
think is really powerful with the the
right story it gives you this kind of
feeling of emotion that kind of like
comes up that like certain stories
really evoke can invoke and Inspire
change certainly so what are the the
pieces or elements that make a story
great and make it relevant to the
corporate world
yeah so there's there's about a handful
of things I think that are really
important probably the most important
too
um the first one is the structure of a
story and and I do think stories have
structure and I hear people tell stories
in the wrong it's the wrong structure in
the wrong order all the time and it
really makes for a much more a poor
story and so there really is a beginning
and middle and an end to the story and
that's part of what I try and take the
reader through is to help them
understand
you know what's the context where what's
the action of the story and what's the
result and if you tell it in a different
order it just doesn't have the same
impact so the structure is one thing the
second most important thing I think is
emotion
um if if your story doesn't have some
kind of emotional element and I don't
mean a tear jerker and you need to have
your your co-workers and peers but
because it doesn't have to be sadness it
could be Joy it could be greed it could
it could be happiness it could be
empathy in fact empathy is the the best
emotion for a business story that I can
think of if you don't have some element
of emotion in it it's probably not a
story it's probably a case study or an
example or an anecdote or something else
but it's not a story so those are the
two most important ones but there are
some others that you could use to make a
good story into a great story like the
element of surprise and using metaphors
and analogies and you know I'll tell you
there's one that I left out and I left
it out I think it's important and I'll
admit that the reason I left it out and
it's one that that you know more about
than anybody I know and it's humor and
yeah I admit to you that I didn't leave
it out because I didn't think it was
important but honestly because I didn't
know how to do it or I mean I'll tell
stories and they'll end up being funny
but I don't know why they were funny
because I'm not a humorist and and it's
it's of all of these things it's the
hardest thing and and you you know this
better than any it's the hardest thing
to teach somebody else to do and that's
because I don't really know when I've
said something funny I really don't know
why it was funny it just gets a laugh
and so humor is definitely an important
part of Storytelling but I didn't feel
like I could teach it adequately so I
just quite frankly left it out and maybe
maybe that's your job then is to write
that chapter
absolutely and maybe to pick up because
I do think that it's an important
element I think one of the things that I
talk about as I talk about humor is that
um to me humor is a little bit of a
broader definition I was actually just
talking with
um a group from peppercott who does uh
they go in and they do stand-up comedy
as part of a training session for
various corporate workplaces and it's a
way to improve morale and do it's a big
team building event because people are
kind of scared and intimidated but they
they teach people how to do stand up and
I've done
um you know comedy boot camps and stuff
like that in the past that I've taught
and one of the big differentiations that
we make is that humor is about making
people smile and comedy is about making
people laugh so humor's a little bit
broader of a context and so I'm just
making people smile doing things a
little bit differently
um things that are incongruous or absurd
or comic kind of that cause Amusement is
the definition behind humor so that's I
think part of it is that you don't
always have to make people laugh but a
lot of it comes from I think to what you
kind of mentioned structure in terms of
uh when people are surprised if you give
them a basically in a formal joke of a
setup and punch line you are setting up
a certain expectation and then the punch
line breaks that expectation and that's
what causes people to laugh they're
going in One Direction and they're
surprised and they they laugh as a
result and the other element is that
emotion I think that sometimes we laugh
just because we've been in that
situation before we feel the truth of uh
in Combi in terms of what you're
expressing on stage and I think that a
lot of times if people are putting those
things in there already if they have
structure and they have that emotion
that you talk about they'll reach some
of the the funny parts naturally and to
your point they may not know why but I
do think that's an important element or
it can be a powerful element of humors
getting people to collapse
intentionally or unintentionally but
being there to
um to embrace it
that makes sense yeah I wish I'd known
that out I had one more chapter in my
book
um yeah so maybe the the future
extension version more
of that so how has it been uh received
obviously it seems like it's gone well
in terms of the ideas and Concepts in
the book it's been knocked out in Forbes
and all these other places and that you
do training that PNG and you speaking
elsewhere and stuff so it seems like
it's something that people
um are starting to believe in have you
found that that's been true people are
seeing the value of stories yeah in fact
it's uh it's exceeded my expectations
like I said I I really mostly wrote the
book for me
um but I'm finding that a lot of other
people are appreciating it as well and
and and to be fair I I think I'm in the
middle or hopefully not the end of but
in the middle of a a Revival of
Storytelling of appreciation and
practice of Storytelling that really
started about 20 years ago and really
picked up about 10 years ago so
um so I'm benefiting from some of that
momentum in the business World
um and yeah and yeah it's showing I
think the book's in his third printing
already and it's been published in Korea
and it'll be published in Japanese next
month and in Indonesia later in the year
and so
um it's not just a local phenomenon as
well so I'm I'm very pleased with with
that kind of uh uptake
yeah I think that that's uh that's great
you're right even as a performance
storytelling is getting you know has had
a Revival just with kind of a moth here
in New York City and
um great storytellers like Mike
Birbiglia and stuff are getting more I'm
going to ride in moving maybe some away
from stand-up comedy where it's just
about laughter and I think story the
other element a story that was maybe not
there in other forms of humor even
performance in terms of straight comedic
is that you have the opportunity to go a
little bit more serious to kind of make
a point and I think sometimes those
Rises and fall in a story can be
incredibly impactful if you're making
people laugh a lot through these stories
and then you hit a moment that's kind of
a little bit more poignant or a little
bit more serious in nature in terms of
oh this is when I had a really tough
time or this was me going through a
transformation or when a leader really
stepped up or didn't step up those
stories can they're emotional lately
they leave an impact on them I think
kind of to your point earlier they leave
an impact more on us than
um just kind of telling a random joke or
even just kind of going through the
normal training and this is a way to
replace some of those elements that you
would normally speak about right
um very cool so uh I guess uh do you
have a favorite story to tell oh yeah
yeah you know um my favorite stories
actually not one that's in the book and
in fact I wouldn't even call it a a
business story but since yes I'm gonna
tell you it's exactly yeah yeah it's
actually about my dad and uh when I when
I was probably 17 years old
um he helped me get a job at the company
that he worked at and I I was a file
clerk basically in the personnel office
um and that's when I learned about
Secretary's Day now they probably don't
call it that these days it's probably
Administrative Professionals Day or
something but this was 30 years ago
right so
um so on Secretary's Day everybody uh
all the secretaries me being one of them
got taken out to lunch by their boss and
they apparently since there were so many
of us at this company in this little
small town they basically rented out the
local one of the local restaurants just
for this day for this all of us at this
one company so here was a you know a
hundred managers and a hundred
secretaries in this uh in this
restaurant for lunch and so to prepare
for that they basically had to pre-pair
the food so that there was only two
options for lunch when you got in there
and one was a club sandwich and one was
a quiche lorraine now this was back in
like 1986
or seven and uh you may not be old
enough to remember this but there was a
book that had just come out a few years
earlier called real men don't eat quiche
and it basically was a book making fun
of the feminization of the American male
as it was a tongue-in-cheek book but it
was highly popular and so basically no
you know self-respecting man after that
book came out would dare eat quiche
because it would brand him as a or
something right so and everybody had
either read the book or heard the book
heard of the book so here we are and I'm
17 years old and obviously you know
still questioning my own you know
manhood and all that kind of stuff so
when the waitress comes around to me of
course I very quickly order the club
sandwich as did every other male in the
the place and most of the women were
ordering the quiche lorraine well it
gets around to my dad so my dad's in the
same company he's in the same room and
he's at the same table that I'm at with
his secretary and it gets around to him
and he says well you know I've never had
a key so how about this how about you
bring me half a quiche and a half a club
sandwich that way if I don't like the
Keisha I still got my club sandwich and
all the men at the table immediately
start making fun one of them and
basically questioning his masculinity in
in terms that I won't repeat on this
family-friendly show and of course
embarrassing the heck out of me is his
son sitting there and I'm just you know
terrified anyway after like two or three
minutes of all the ribbing he can take
he finally calls the waitress back over
and of course that just sends the guys
like howling with you know high fives
and like they had they had won right
they had beat him into submission and he
calls the waitress back over and he says
I'm sorry I need to change my order I
ordered a half a club sandwich and a
half a quiche and I need you to take
back that half a club sandwich and I
want you to bring me the whole damn
quiche and there was silence at the
table and all their draws their jaws
like dropped and I to this day I don't
know if my dad actually likes quiche but
I can tell you on that day he ate every
bite of that quiche with a smile on his
face and and you know he probably didn't
intend to do this but you know I learned
a lesson that day about what it means to
be a man or to be an adult in general a
free thing talking adult and about not
caring what other people think and
standing up for what you believe in and
not being you know ridiculed into
submission and he didn't intend to teach
me all those lessons man he did and my
respect for my father was never higher
than at that moment and so to this now
today here it is 30 years later and I've
got two two boys of my own 13 and 8
years old and I tell them that story
when I see them being influenced by
their peers to do something that they
don't want to do just to remind them
that a real man doesn't do that you know
you you do what you think is the right
thing to do and I just find it an
incredibly helpful story and like I said
that that's not a business story but the
stories I tell at work are are really no
different there are stories about
something that happened to somebody
doesn't have to be me or somebody
learned a lesson and that they can learn
from that lesson too and so and that's
why I generally share them but that's
one of my favorite yeah no I think and I
think it's a great story because you
know with your kids or even I think even
within a corporate you know world you
could go in and the lesson could be you
know hey don't get influenced by just
because everyone else around you is
doing something or don't be influenced
by friends that kind of stuff you can
give kind of that memorized
you know line of dialogue of what it is
that you're supposed to say how
effective would that be right exactly
but the fact that you have this story
and you go through emotions and it's
like more engaging so you're like
actually listening to it and then by the
end you're like you have that head
shaking like while you're telling the
story I thought of uh when I was an
intern at uh PNG uh one of the guys
around there since around this uh link
to this book uh which was kind of
popular at the time called look at my
striped shirt and it was basically a
similar kind of tongue-in-cheek type
thing of like how young professionals uh
wore striped shirts uh into the
workplace vertical stripes and just kind
of like the some of the Cockiness that
went around to it and also how like they
were so young but didn't really know
what was going on or that kind of thing
and at the time I was wearing a bunch of
striped shirts and uh unfortunately I
wasn't like your father where I wasn't
influenced by that but like I guess yeah
like subconsciously like now all of my
shirts and I enjoy it all of my shirts
are solid uh colored kind of buttoned up
shirts
um and so apparently that just kind of
them sitting around that book and kind
of joking about it I was like all right
well I guess I won't wear striped shirts
but uh while you're telling a certain
stories you know it evokes images in our
heads one of being able to sit there and
actually you you know I can start to see
what it's like with this what was
probably like at the rest of the
restaurant but I also it brings up my
own memories and as a result of that can
easily relate these messages again as
opposed to just saying don't do this or
do this instead so I think it's actually
a great example of kind of the power of
story very good thank you I I enjoyed it
very cool so if people are interested uh
obviously I'll uh kind of share the
information on uh on the book which is
available
um online in a couple of other places
I'm guessing what is the work for people
to go to get the book I guess is the
question I'm asking yeah it's it's
available just about anywhere you would
normally buy your books on you know
Amazon or Barnes and Noble all the
online places it's probably in every
Barnes Noble store in the in this
country and it's online and most others
so wherever you wherever your listeners
buy books probably my book would be
there and if they have trouble they can
just go to lead with the story.com which
is my website and they can get directed
somewhere like that okay great and then
should you also do
um other things as well kind of with
like so speaking and training and stuff
so people are really fast fascinated by
this idea of story and stuff where I
think where can they find more where can
I see more of you yeah so I I do and in
fact as soon as we get off the phone
here I'm headed to the airport to go to
Dallas Texas where I've got a keynote
speech but so um yeah I do corporate
training
um and speaking on this topic to teach
Executives or or others how to use
storytelling effectively at work and you
can find all all of that information and
some videos of me on my website uh to
kind of see what that looks like so
thank you for asking okay great
um yes I'll certainly share that
information any uh any final thoughts or
any less things you want to say before
we sign off well um I actually just
started my my second book and um and I'd
love to know what you think about it
because it's very different than the
first one but with one uh one thing in
common and that is story and so if this
the first book is using storytelling to
make you a better leader at work the
next one's going to be using stories to
make you a better leader home so it's
basically like the story I told you
about my dad I'm quite certain that'll
be in there but it's yeah it's it's a
collection of stories to help parents
teach their kids wisdom as opposed to
doing what you were saying like just
wagging your finger at them and telling
them you know be kind to strangers
because that just doesn't work so we'll
see if we can start a second collection
of uh of more personally useful stories
yeah I think that that's uh that's great
and an important element of that um kind
of hitting both sides of that work-life
balance or work-life efficiency kind of
in terms of the the two things that we
spend a lot of our time uh on in
adulthood is is parenting and work stuff
so I think it's great that you're uh
you're tackling both
well Paul thanks so much for uh for
joining us today as I mentioned I'll
kind of share some of the links um up
there and uh hopefully people are now uh
inspired as well to continue to to use
humor in the workplace but uh today is
an example through uh through some
storytelling so thanks so much Paul
very good thanks for having me
[Music]